well as karamay mentioned my name is
allison fish and yes I run an
aquaculture business so every time I
introduced myself someone says do you
ever get the convention that you're you
know your last name and I'm thinking
every single time I introduced myself I
get it but it's I do feel like I found
my family's calling perhaps we are Cape
Cod family and maybe we were fishermen
back in the day who knows I am an som
grad of 2008 so I'm coming up on my five
year anniversary have a background
before i came to som I was in the food
industry but on the gourmet industry
side i ran restaurants in San Francisco
I worked in nonprofit fundraising for
science education pretty traditional som
background kind of all over the place
and then came here to really make that
transition into how do I help grow green
businesses you know specifically I
wanted to go work in corporate America
and lead change from within the
organization verses from the outside
that's what led me to dupont kind of a
surprising outcome not something i would
have expected when i first came here to
Yale but it has been exactly what I'm
looking for and has given me
opportunities I never expected to have
so quickly out of school where I really
am working with the daily challenges of
how do you provide a more sustainable or
a greener product to a consumer with
less impact on the environment better
for their health but still find a way to
make money and get you know
multinational organizations involved in
NGO support and these kinds of things
and it's it's been a really fascinating
journey I'm working with this business
for about three and a half years and was
recently made the business director in
August so now get to have that full
accountability for it which is also
another sort of interesting and exciting
world to be in but today I hope I can
provide you a little bit more of the
commercial perspective and some of the
challenges you face and trying to reach
these ideals or you know in just
starting something like this so unique
both from a technology side from within
a corporation but also on the marketing
side i mean the consumers
as much as they preach they want these
solutions they want these offerings
they're not always necessarily willing
to pay for them or they're not always as
well informed as you might hope or they
might be informed with misinformation
and so it becomes very much a complex
challenge around education communication
how do you build credibility how do you
build trust how do you engage the
consumers to get them to sort of get
that call to action so that they do
actually begin to make purchasing
behaviors that do benefit the overall
environment and continue to promote
these types of products in the future so
with that I did put together a number of
slides I would ask that you guys be a
little more interactive or you know if
things are interesting to you or you
want to stop and talk about something in
particular we can go deeper I might jump
around a little bit but I did want to
give you sort of the overall overview of
what is our offering what's the business
opportunity what are the challenges
around being within something like
DuPont but also partnering with a
smaller company down in a developing
country and then moving on to their what
is really the market challenge and how
do we convince people or what are the
different ways or what are the things
we're trying to overcome in order to
make this a successful venture so with
that this is kind of verlos mantra I
think all of you have been on our
website seeing a couple of things but we
really believe there is a right way to
do aquaculture and that it needs to be
part of the solution I won't focus on
feeding the world that have been asked
not to do that at all but we do feel
that there's not enough wild fish in the
in the ocean as many of you know and
therefore there is a need to figure out
how to get aquaculture right one of our
sort of constant mantras or
communications is that we're not perfect
like we've come out with a pretty
comprehensive solution to some of
aquaculture challenges but we also
realize this is a journey and we've only
come so far there are many things that
we believe we do really well and there
are some things we realized we still
need to do a lot of work on we have
worked with some of the top in NGOs
around the country or around the world
to identify our key priorities and
that's how we
started and really focused our efforts
to how we will begin this venture but
then it again it's a continuous journey
and there are some things that we've
committed to for 2015 and we're always
looking for that continuous improvement
of what we can do next and what's what's
really important so that's where this
commitment to adaption and adaptation
and responsibility is what we believe
produces our healthy and premium quality
salmon verlis those farming practices
are based on three main principles just
sort of at the highest level and then we
can go into whatever details you want in
terms of how we raise our fish and what
we think is important but the number one
thing for us is we believe healthy fish
are the best tasting fish it's just it
seems to be proving itself right left
and right so we believe good husbandry
practices taking care with the Sam and
making sure they have the right
nutrition the right diet getting good
exercise being grown in my clean and
pristine environments all these things
are ways that we believe promote the
health of the salmon and therefore gives
the consumer the best tasting salmon and
that's really how you can win them over
because of the end of the day they
really buy on taste and price
unfortunately the second one is reducing
the impact on wild seafood populations I
know many of you have asked questions
about our GM East and and really the
value proposition we bring around
lowering that fish and fish out ratio we
can go into some more details around
that but it's you know it's about the
feeder fish but it's also about
protecting the wild salmon we can't just
you know keep consuming the wild salmon
because we're going to run out and then
finally protecting the areas where we
farm we farmed out in Patagonia one of
the most beautiful places in the world
if you haven't had a chance to go a
highly recommend it there are very few
people so very little little interaction
but it's an ideal environment for salmon
the water temperatures are good the
waters are really deep you're in an
extreme environment where you've had
lots of volcanoes and earthquakes so
you're in this fewer derya where the
waters get 80 meters deep super close to
the shore and provide you this great
sort of ability to have good tidal flow
the ability for the water to filter and
nurture itself you get sixty percent I
think sixty percent of the time of the
year it rains so you get constantly get
new water plus you have unfortunately
melting glaciers but they're feeding the
ocean
well and it's just it's an ideal
environment for the salmon so for us
it's it given that we've chosen these
places to farm we it's our
responsibility to maintain and protect
them as well so that's really the
guiding principles for everything that
we do again we're not perfect so I'm
sure you'll find flaws in arm in our
strategy and our philosophy but just
kind of wanted to set the tone
harmoniously raised salmon we believe is
a comprehensive solution there are so
many issues with aquaculture and it can
you can go on forever about it we keep
recall our story sort of the yes and
sort of story because we always have
more to tell but the main principles are
things we focused on is that fish and
fish out ratio of how do we reduce the
amount of feeder fish required in the
Salmons diet and still provide healthy
salmon number two lopen densities we
believe that this is one way to provide
a healthy environment for the salmon to
grow in and have less impact on the
areas where we farm now having lopen
densities does it mean we just go make
more pens and so you still have the same
amount of biomass in one region we're
actually reducing the amount of biomass
in a geographical region as a result of
lopen densities to you've got just the
salmon have a lot more room to swim a
lot more exercise our salmon are leaner
lower fat content than traditionally
farmed salmon that's in part due to the
low pen densities but also to the diet
we've designed post-harvest following
the super important part about
protecting the ecosystems after every
harvest our farms lie fallow for three
to six months they don't just lie fallow
at our farm they actually life I'll also
in a surrounding neighborhood a
geographical region this allows the
water again mother nature to take care
of itself nurture it get the water flow
tidal flow going through so it's
important to protecting this where the
areas where we farm but also good for
the salmon too if there is a challenge
or there is some disease outbreak or
some bacteria hopefully you give it a
chance to sort of disappear or find you
know find someone else or some other
animals to attach to we use no hormones
or preventative antibiotics we use a
naturally-occurring beta-carotene from
fafi a-- no copper antifouling on the
nets I don't know how familiar you guys
are with some of the stuff but just it's
a laundry list
for us it was there isn't one solution
there isn't one problem it's how do we
look at all the challenges for
aquaculture and try to address the most
important ones today and then can commit
to that continuous improvement the end
of the day premium care means great
tasting salmon and then we also know
that this is not an easy sell it's a
complex story for us to tell and it's an
even more complex story for our
customers to tell so then it becomes
this how do we support that how do we
educate the consumer how do we provide
materials and videos and POS material or
point-of-sale material to help our
customers sell the product because if we
don't sell the product we're not going
to reach our sustainability goals if we
are a niche market we're not actually
preserving any feeder fish we're not
actually benefiting anyone by being a
small market that's only serving a
hundred people a night or what not and
coming from a high-end restaurant
background that was something I really
grappled with like sort of this idea
that there was precious food and there
was food that was good for the masses
and this also this idea of if you make a
small or even medium-sized improvement
to an industrialized food system you can
have so much more impact than if you
start this is my perspective I agree I
sorry that I don't want to you know
force my opinion than anyone but the
idea is that you can actually have so
much more impact than if you start a
small company that's feeding a hundred
people a week or people a day but it was
something I personally had to grapple
with for a long time finally we can't do
this alone we need the support and the
credibility of the environmental
community and that's something that
we've worked with since the beginning of
our inception so yeah sure
uh-huh bathiya yeah so it's a natural
coloring it's a it's a naturally
occurring beta-carotene in the wild and
it's actually I believe a yeast is its
actual makeup but it's what we put in
the diet to provide the antioxidant in
the beta carotene did you break down
your in the customer sales who is what
what percent would be restaurant
customers versus supermarkets and I have
a map later on that shows you who they
all are like in terms of our regional
distribution right now we're about 5050
food service versus retail and we'll
talk about that sort of go to market
strategy in a little bit there was a lot
of surprises that we encountered from
when we started versus where we are
today uh the true for last so different
so it's really this fish and fish out
ratio that's really unique to us anyone
else can do any of those things that we
listed on there the only thing no one
else can do is get the fish and fish out
ratio down to one to one I'm going to
spend two minutes on what the fish in
fish out ratio is I just so everyone
kind of has a basic understanding salmon
don't make their own omega-3s they get
it in their diet just like we do salmon
need a certain level of omega-3s for a
strong immune system historically those
omega-3s have come from feeder fish so
the small oily fish herring anchovies
mackerel in order to provide them with
the omega-3s now in traditionally farmed
salmon it takes roughly four pounds a
feeder fish to raise one pound of salmon
ultimately a really bad use of resources
if you think about what goes in versus
what goes out and the reason it takes so
many feeder fish it's not because of the
fish meal it's not because the protein
it's because of the oil it's all about
those omega-3s so you can have a fish
and fish out ratio of one to one from
the protein perspective but if you're
looking at the oil perspective that's
when you get into the four to one ratio
and so what they do is they harvest four
pounds of feeder fish extract the fish
oil put it in the diet and then of
course you know the rest of it goes to
other uses /
you know chicken farms or what not but
at the end of the day they still had to
take four pounds of feeder fish out to
get the enough oil to feed the salmon to
give them a strong enough nutritional
diet for their well-being this has been
one of the biggest challenges of the
industry there aren't a lot of omega-3
resources out there and if you look at
you know the monterey bay aquarium's
website or if you look at WWF one of
their top complaints about aquaculture
is the feeder fish or wild fish in the
feed for salmon so this is something we
have been able to achieve by replacing
75 percent of our feeder fish in the
diet or the oil from the feeder fish
with an omega-3 rich East yes this is a
genetically modified you some will go
into some details around that but it's
something that we feel it truly is
offering a solution to an environmental
challenge that no one else has been able
to find you can look at flaxseed you can
look at algae you can look at all these
other sources of omega-3 s but none of
them are as efficient or effective as
the omega-3 rich East that we've been
able to to come up with and one of the
questions that came up from you guys on
Tuesday was is this a proprietary yeast
and it is that this is something that
DuPont developed and it's something that
we are the only ones we believe who can
who can reach these targets and it's
definitely our main differentiation and
competitive advantage again it's not our
only advantage because we have a whole
complete solution and believe the whole
package is what's important but it is
something no one else can copy or at
least would take a long time for them to
copy yeah
I don't have that information the top of
my head unfortunately I'm sorry East
Cape I'm sure sure um I would so I not
sure where the original idea came from i
would say DuPont has a really strong
innovation engine and they all have a
very large crd group so folks central
research and development they're just
they're like crazy mad scientist where
there's trying to come up with new stuff
that's how they came up with nylon
that's how they came up with Divac or
all the things that they come up with
their like artists they get very engaged
in something and they just take it to
its fullest you know creative outlook so
they started with you know biotechnology
about 25 years ago and this was just
something that they were able to
discover some opportunities around it
was about 10 years of work to develop
this yeast and they're still working on
developing better more efficient
versions of these the essence of it came
originally from an algae so we gave the
omega-3 making capability from algae to
a yeast and that's what we're the actual
modification happened and then we
ferment the yeast just like you would
ferment any east from used in bread or
used in beer or whatnot so just you add
sugar and water and just ferment and
large tanks right now no this is the
only one we did originally when we the
first program that was launched with
this this technology was a human
supplement so you know how fish oil is
this huge rage and everyone's taking
supplements we offered a vegan fish oil
essentially a vegan omega-3 tablet but
unfortunately I think our cost position
was probably out of proportion with the
marketplace and also ours is an EPA
omega-3 versus a DHA and right now most
people are familiar with DHA as an Omega
Omega 3 and its benefits the EPA story
hasn't quite reached consumers yet but I
would say that's probably we might have
been just too early in front of our time
the pharmaceutical interest is really
in Puri PA so the fact that we have this
capability we are exploring
opportunities and that because there's a
lot of heart hello sorry heart health
benefits around it and then there's
there's lots of ideas around pet food
and various other food supplements and
these kinds of things but the
applications haven't been fully explored
if you look at where the omega-3s go in
the marketplace I believe sixty percent
of them are used by the aquaculture
industry and so that's why this was one
of the top priorities of focusing on it
plus it was one of the biggest concerns
because it was a poor use of resources
yeah we currently are and I'll talk
about our partner in a minute but we're
currently in an exclusive for the
Americas with our partner and so we're
going to stick with them for a little
while it's taking quite a bit of
investment I'll talk a little bit about
the business model why we chose this
partner why we chose the model that we
did because it's important to look a
little at the value chain and understand
where you can capture the most value but
that might be something we do in the
future it also we've also considered
licensing out the whole harmoniously
raised concept you know is that
something where if people met all of
these criteria that we've established to
be what ver la so harmoniously raised
means can they use the branding and the
the position that that equity that we
develop over time in order to promote
their product but it's you know there's
lots of unknowns in that future we got
to get this one down right first good
okay so why does it matter why does fish
and fish out matter it matters because
according to the FAO we've harvested
about seventy percent of fish
populations over or at sustainable
levels mostly depleted and exploited
there's a maximum amount of feeder fish
we can take out of the ocean every year
and we reach those numbers in the late
90s so in the late 90s we started taking
out a certain amount of feeder fish it's
they are very well men managed fisheries
out of Peru and Chile and out of
Scandinavia but we've kind of maxed out
what we can take out of the water in
terms of feeder fish and that number
doesn't fluctuate from year to you
at the same time the salmon industry
goes up seven to ten percent a year so
the demand continues to increase for the
omega-3s think about the fish oil
supplement industry that's just gone
through the roof and now if
pharmaceutical industries are also
looking at this as a major resource it's
a problem there aren't enough omega-3 s
available in the marketplace so we need
to find alternative solutions if you
didn't find alternatives to the omega-3s
you could reduce the omega-3s in the
diet like you could just not put as much
fish oil in the diet substitute it with
vegetable oil but then you're going to
compromise the immune system of the
salmon and potentially open yourself up
to more disease and risk given some of
the circumstances as I said omega-3s
continue to be a consumer focus and I
can't it as we focus on wellness and
health and then at the end of the day we
can't take more feeder fish out of the
ocean because they play such an
important role in the food chain right
so there's this whole idea of how do you
pass energy through the food chain and
it starts with the phytoplankton and
moves up through the food chain until
you get to the salmon and by taking the
feeder fish out of that important role
it just it really breaks up that that
system and can significantly hurt the
biodiversity of the areas so while we do
all these wonderful things that what we
believe good things around aquaculture
at the end of the day the consumer
really cares about taste or you might
say the buyer really cares about taste
that's where we're really getting
persistence back so we just continuously
have to come back to flavor profile
tastes and it's such a weird dichotomy
of a world to live in where you're
promoting this sort of ecological story
this health story but the end of the day
it's an experience you're eating the
salmon you're enjoying the salmon and
I'll talk a little bit more about the
food craze in this country and how that
really sort of adds noise to the the
conversation and makes it a little bit
harder of a cell so a partnership
opportunity and challenges so I'm going
to switch gears a little and go into the
business perspective and talk some about
the partnership so salmon aquaculture
opportunity global farm salmon markets
are about 1.4 million dollar match or
million metric tons around the world
that's about a 14 billion dollar
business
and the US alone you're looking at a 4.5
billion dollar market opportunity that's
for the total salmon market if you look
at the farm salmon it's only about three
billion and this continues to grow seven
to ten percent a year right now if you
look at the salmon break up it's about
forty percent wild sixty percent farmed
and as you all know you can I can't take
out any more wild salmon than you
already are though there's a lot of new
stuff happening around ranching has
anyone ever heard of ranching wild
salmon where you're you know you keep
them until a certain age and then you
release them into the wild later in life
so it's kind of a half farming hybrid
situation key market trends there's a
commoditization of traditionally farm
salmon people are starting to say I want
to know where my food comes from how is
it raised is it good for me is it good
for the environment now that that size
of how many consumers really care about
that is still a little bit unknown or
whether or not they're willing to make
significant changes to their purchasing
behaviour is unknown but we're trying to
focus on that sustainable seafood and
traceability started with produce went
to meet went to dairy see if it's kind
of the last frontier is this is this
something that consumers really want to
focus on do they want sustainable
options do they care about it do they
want to do enough research to understand
it do they want to farm that that
decision out to people like the Monterey
Bay Aquarium or to Whole Foods you know
what what are their choices how do they
how do they use eco-labels all these
things because seafoods pretty complex
and given that every single species is
different and whether it's wild vs.
farmed you're looking at different
issues different challenges and the
consumer to be honest doesn't have the
time or the the real patients to dive
into those details traceability that's
been a huge trend particularly in the
seafood industry there's been a lot of
articles recently about 60-percent
mislabeling happening out there in the
marketplace so you don't even know what
you're eating so I guess they you could
say well at least they're labeling but
if their labeling wrong is that really a
benefit but it is something that we try
to address through some of the materials
that we've developed and then consumer
focus on antibiotics there's a general
stigma that if an animal needs
antibiotics there's something wrong
with it whether it's there something
wrong with your farming practice or
you're compromising their health in some
way shape or form and so there's just a
general negative feeling about
antibiotics even though if they had
children and their child got sick they
would probably feed them antibiotics
without thinking about it so it's an
interesting discussion to have and and
as you explore the details around
farming you can learn a lot more about
you know how difficult these decisions
might be because if our if our fish do
get sick you there is an animal well for
sorry animal welfare law that sort of
forces us to feed them antibiotics so
something that we have to to address the
salmon industries is not very
diversified I would say there's some big
players around the world marine harvest
multi export cermak Leroy most of them
Norwegian companies that then expanded
to other parts of the world the Chilean
industry itself was probably started by
her mostly started by Norwegian farmers
and it has been really fully exploited
by Norwegian farmers but there are a
couple of local groups like aqua chili
which is one of the ones that we work
with down there that have really led the
charge on being entrepreneurs and
growing a very young it's only about a
25 26 year-old industry down in the
Patagonia region the latest thing has
been premium salmon and people who are
really trying to differentiate
themselves branding is not normal in
seafood I don't know if many of you have
noticed but you don't go to a seafood
counter and ask for a particular brands
of cod or swordfish it's just sort of
ish who it's the only option you have
well if there is swordfish but halibut
oh you might have Alaskan halibut but
it's a regional branding there's not
actually a company branding and so
what's been interesting on this journey
is that when people say to me well isn't
farmed salmon bad and I say to them well
it depends on the farmer they say well I
don't know who the farmer is and that
sort of leads to a whole new questions
of course you don't because we haven't
we haven't gotten that far in this
business and in this industry and so
this is a whole new territory for this
for this industry to mark on and we
don't know if it's going to be important
or not we found that organic has
actually taken a pretty decent hold on
some consumers and that's just because
they have a positive affinity with
organic even though it means absolutely
nothing in seafood there's no
international standard for organic
seafood today there's 13 European
different European standards and I'm not
really they don't align at all so
there's a couple you know consistencies
throughout the standards but they're not
relevant but because a consumer is
comfortable with the word they're
willing to pay more for it and they just
feel like Oh must be must be good so
that's something that has been
interesting in our learning as well but
a couple of things you guys watch the
lock to our video hope you enjoyed David
Suzuki's attack on Loch Duart schooner
Bay is a recent brand that came out
interesting concept they per day promote
themselves as being very sustainable if
you look at them they've actually
haven't changed their practices at all
they're owned by Greek which is a pretty
big supplier of salmon or producer of
salmon and the only thing they've done
is they've taken the top six percent of
their production and branded at schooner
Bay and they've said this is a this is a
better salmon and but then they try to
support it with sustainability claims
and you're like but you haven't improved
anything you haven't really changed
anything so it's just it's it's an
interesting concept to see how marketing
can be really strong without really a
story to back it up it can be splashy it
can be engaging and they're getting all
the chef's on board and it's all about
this sort of premium quality or if you
think about wine it's like the premier
grapes it's the premier salmon then
recently and you guys have a couple of
you brought this up as well as there's
the land-based farming that's coming
this is something that's coming it's not
here yet there's a you know very small
farms around the world right now that
are testing it out and there's a lot of
unknowns out there economics carbon
footprint health of the salmon there's
you know they're packing them in like
crazy but there's a lot of great things
where you don't have any impact on the
ocean you don't have any impact on the
ecosystem so there's a lot of pros and
cons and I think as we learn more about
that opportunity we'll have to see what
makes sense in the long run it's not
like we have a ton of land to be
provided for
as well there's some land issues coming
up in the world too so there's just a
number of there's so many things to
think about there's so many dynamics and
trade-offs to consider in these types of
business decisions and even in
developing what you're doing and how
you're going to try and do it it becomes
super complex very very quickly mother
giving my child man go to the doctor and
the doctor would say this campus is what
your child needs and I would guess that
the fear about eating salmon antibiotic
is I don't the doctor has told me that
this is the antibiotic that I mean I
don't know it's going to be good for me
or about me or effective so can you talk
a little bit about testing humans of the
antibiotics that you so um just so
everyone knows if you feed your salmon
antibiotics you have to wait by law in
the u.s. I think you have to wait four
to six weeks until you can harvest that
fish and they do test the fish to make
sure there's no residue left in the same
and flesh at all so there would be no
antibiotic antibiotics remaining in the
meat itself in there never can be now I
would say based on what I've been
reading lately as a consumer I may or
may not be confident that my fish have
been tested I mean the USDA and FDA or
whatever have not done a good job of
testing fish that have come into this
country from from other parts of the
world so of course it's a reasonable
risk but for us it is it is definitely
what we do we do not feed our salmon
antibiotics unless a veterinarian tells
us we have to and that there is a
disease identified we have veterinarians
come out to our farms every week and
spend time with the salmon they watch
this am and they test to Sam and they
monitor the salmon and in its for us
it's part of our value proposition I
think one of the bigger concerns about
antibiotics from an environmental
perspective and I and I apologize I
don't know all the details but i think
it's the impact of the waste going into
the ocean so the waste from the fish
carrying that antibiotic and then the
fear of creating a resistance antibiotic
resistance in the environment is just a
general greater fear i would say there
are a lot of rules around which
antibiotics are
allowed to use in salmon and which are
not some countries have better
regulation than others but if you look
at some of the standards that are being
developed by NGOs there they're trying
to find ways to standardize they're not
saying no antibiotics but they're saying
putting provisions around how they're
used or which ones are used and and the
different ways that they are fed to the
salmon so those are the types of things
they're trying to control or put some
controls around to understand really the
true implications of the antibiotic use
but for the most part there really isn't
a prophylactic use of antibiotics
there's no benefit to having salmon just
fed antibiotics for no reason it's
actually really expensive doesn't make
sense so as you all know I work for
DuPont and what's really fun is that
what we make is yeast we make biomass it
looks like fish feed actually comes from
the algae as I mentioned but what we
sell is salmon and it's it's just a very
different discussion and it's it's it's
a different way of doing business to
work with a downstream business partner
and invest your time in there their
success benefiting from their success as
well but it's just it's a very unique
way of doing business and I would say
most people in my company are still not
comfortable with it and feel like
there's a lot of risk about being
involved even in that relationship
downstream I would say yes we sell
salmon but again we're selling an idea
we're selling an experience it's gourmet
it's you know whatever it's it's
whatever you whatever your relationship
is to food but it's it's a it's an
emotional thing it's not just a
technical thing it's not just an
environmental thing now you look like
you're staring what is it a poached egg
poached egg with salmon and this is I
have to hit this is where my food
background in San Francisco actually has
come in handy quite a bit is to learn
how to talk this language versus just
the technical aspect of GM yeast you
might think why dupont dupont doesn't
seem like a good fit but they do have
good intentions they just not same
farmers so we really had to look for a
partner to figure out how to make this
technology accessible for a good purpose
and a good cause but just for a quick
background I don't know how many of you
what you all think of dupont you
probably think of the chemical giants or
you probably think of I don't know paint
something like that that's what I
thought about but there's three main
mega trends and focus areas of the
company and sort of how they how we're
driving our portfolio today is around
feeding the world reducing dependency on
fossil fuels and keeping people in the
environment safe so if you looked at our
portfolio of products I think we're
about thirty to forty percent food now
food and nutrition which no one would
ever consider or think about
historically energy there's a lot of
work on biofuels cellulosic biofuels
there's a lot of work on well
photovoltaics which is not doing so
great these days but then there's also a
lot of just material you know how do we
get lightweight materials that are not
using petroleum as their baseline and
also provide sort of our customers give
our customers the ability to reduce
their dependency on fossil fuels so we
work with Toyota and give them lighter
materials to use in their priuses or in
their cars or these kinds of things to
help benefit that cause and then finally
protecting people in the environment and
there's a number of things on that sense
but century glass Kevlar these kinds of
things sort of flame retardant materials
that protect lives and the environment
yeah so we book about two years ago we
bought danisco I don't know if you're
familiar with Dennis color a Danish
company they do a lot of enzymes food
enzymes and so they're in the baking
industry the yogurt industry the beer
industry and I'm still learning about it
as well but I would say that that would
be probably ten percent of our food
ingredients today then we have do have a
crop business called pioneer which is
genetically modified crops but it is
something that is is huge for us as well
and then we have salmon which is tiny
this big but it is it is a growing part
of our focus we also do a lot of food
safety testing so we have a lot of
things that test e coli a lot of
programs that you know that are being
used in developing countries to ensure
that the food that is being delivered is
safe and free of disease but it is
definitely a growing part of our our
company encourage you to check out the
website because I'm probably not doing
it as much justice as I should there's
we're really diversified and sometimes
it gets very confusing to understand
where we're playing and where we're not
playing and I work there which is I
can't imagine what it's like to be on
the outside partnership so as I
mentioned DuPont's not a farmer they
know nothing about salmon farming and so
we had to find someone that we could
work with and I'll talk a little bit
about how we went out with the yeast
initially to talk to stakeholders and do
some consumer research but at the end of
the day we ended up finding a partner
down in Chile called aqua chile and I
just kind of wanted to highlight some of
the difficulties or challenges or even
differences between the two companies
and what they were trying to achieve
here you have theirs we're not enough
joint venture so we act like a joint
venture but we're not legally bound or
there's not an LLC it's what we're doing
is a joint development agreement so it's
a you know I think that's I don't know
if it's a 10 to 15 year agreement with
specific geographical region focus and
with particular roles and
responsibilities of each of the partners
but imagine you've got this 211 year old
company coming in and talking to this 30
year old company and you've got DuPont
in Wilmington Delaware it's been around
forever it's sort of the old established
guard and then you've got this very
entrepreneurial startup mindset of a
small company down in Chile I don't know
if you guys have ever been down to Chile
but it's you know there's salmon
industry is actually one of the largest
industries for the country but there's
very few people in Chile so it's you
know it's a very startup small lets you
know make things happen kind of
environment where is it DuPont we're
75,000 people across 60 or 48 countries
and we move a little slower it takes a
little while for us to make decisions
and we're really data-driven we're
engineering driven it's all about you
know sort of
being very sure about any decision you
make where they kind of fly by the seat
of their pants so bringing these two
cultures together and creating a new
organization that's trying to solve some
of these big big challenges has been
super difficult other differences would
be you know there were commodity sales
focused industry commodity salmon a lot
of the products DuPont brings our
premium value there at the higher end of
the spectrum it's a different
conversation with your in your sales
targets are in your go-to-market
strategy financially significant
difference you've got a 500 million
dollar company versus a 38 billion
dollar company you had a different
relationship to nonprofit organizations
DuPont has been working with the
environmental NGO community for the last
20 years you know it started off early
years with compliance but then moved
into how do we think about new solutions
to address some of these big problems
whereas aqua chili so so I'm sorry back
to dupont we actually often sit at the
table with the NGO community and we sit
down and we talked to them about water
ways we can explore work together to
come up with these ideas I actually
found DuPont through one of those
opportunities i worked at EDF when i was
here at school i did my internship at
EDF and we they were working with dupont
at the time on some nanotechnology risk
assessment tools so to me that was my
first introduction to them was through
the NGO community so there you know very
established relationships with multi
stakeholders when we first started
working with aqua Chile they didn't want
to talk to the NGOs the NGOs were their
worst enemy they were the own their
being attacked weekly by NGOs so how
could you even consider having a
relationship them let alone
collaborating with them to come up with
how we were going to raise our salmon
and that's exactly what we ended up
doing but it was a push in a pole and a
given a take and all kinds of things so
it's definitely being you know having
technology is great and having solutions
is wonderful how you find ways to get
them to market can be very challenging
and different and how you find the
capabilities different organizations and
bring different cultures together to be
successful just goes along for the
complexity
of the whole thing any questions about
the partnership so this is a little bit
about the value chain I don't know how
many of you know the salmon value chain
but there's if you think about it I
think about it from the omega-3
producers I'm sorry but that's the the
by grounding starting point but that
omega-3 then goes to the fish feed
producers the fish feed producers
selfish fee to the fish farmers and then
the fish farmers sell to the retailers
to distributors in the restaurants and
then that's down to the consumer or the
end user are you guys if you look at
most of these markets they're all
commodity this is commodity this is
commodity but there's a lot of value to
be captured between it this transition
turn as well as this transition now do
partner they couldn't come here they did
try that with the human supplement but
it wasn't able to reach that and but
this is really where some value could be
captured but it encouraged us to create
a unique business model where we skipped
over the fish food producers because
most of the time DuPont is a material or
an ingredient provider and they just
sell directly to the producers and then
you know don't really know how it gets
used down chain at all but because there
was not a lot of all these markets where
commodity and our technology was still
pretty high value and actually to be
honest not cheap we had to find a
different way to make it a profitable
opportunity or venture for both business
partners and that's how we chose to go
downstream and work with the fish farmer
invest in branding a salmon product and
bringing that to market if you look at
how we split our work DuPont develops
and supplies the omega-3 biomass aqua
Chile does pay us for the biomass to
help mitigate the risk we I'm sorry and
I'm skipping I guess I skipped a line
here together we define how we're going
to raise this product like we define
what our value proposition is going to
be what are the different practices we
were going to incorporate and engage the
experts to help define that but aqua
chili is required or is responsible for
the raising of the salmon so they own
the operations and the management of the
farms
and that that's all there's a lot of
sort of risk involved in that you know
we don't have the daily reporting or
vision or access to what's going on at
the farms and sometimes there are some
things that come up that you're like how
come you didn't tell us sooner how come
we didn't know that you know there were
some issues sooner than this or that we
had to feed them antibiotics we find out
four weeks later and it can be a little
bit alarming and concerning and you have
to figure out how do you bring again
those two cultures together to norms and
practices to come up with something
that's comfortable for both parties so
that you can really achieve the goals
that you've set out for yourselves
together we partner on marketing in the
selling of ver la so and then that
results in we share the premium value of
the velocity miam as well so it's very
unusual business model like I said
without being a JV it becomes a little
bit more complicated because there's we
don't have a separate legal entity but
it works well from a lot of levels and
by us being able to work with aqua Chile
aqua Chile actually owns the brain we've
given them the brand they own the salmon
they own that sort of whole distribution
aspect of it and we see ourselves as Co
marketers this gives us a lot of leeway
when you're coming from a company like
DuPont who has very strict branding
guidelines and you know if we hadn't
done this if it had been a DuPont brand
or co-own brand we'd have to have that
silly oval DuPont oval all over the
place and to be honest if you're trying
to sell salmon the last thing you want
to lead with is the DuPont oval now
don't get me wrong we don't hide that
from our customers we do talk about
DuPont's role we do talk about the yeast
we talk about the GM East but you don't
want to be leaving into that
conversation with it you don't want to
have this lovely little fish with a red
circle around it and DuPont through the
middle it's just it's not going to work
at a consumer level it's not going to
work at a at a at a at a b2b level as
well and i would say that today no one
thinks of dupont is a food company we
did by dennis go to a years ago and i
believe in 5-10 years people will think
of dupont as a food company and at some
point these will meet up and we can
then leverage that a little bit more but
today it's it's just it doesn't make
sense if we want this to succeed we have
to establish our own personality our own
values our own ethics in order to really
to drive the story forward and to get
people to engage because I did as much
as is let's see how do i express this I
know there's an anti-corporate movement
out there we've all been involved in or
I've thought about it and DuPont's
probably just there's not enough
information out there so people don't
really understand what DuPont's trying
to do and I can't say everything the
DuPont's done or does is good and I
don't agree with everything they do
either so I get and understand the
Association could have negative effect
but I do believe that what ver los is
doing is valuable and important and it
couldn't have been done without DuPont's
backing without their technology and
innovation and without their vision so
it is still a very important part of
this business venture thoughts comments
yeah
it's an ongoing process i would say that
has many stages so we had like the
development phase and now we're in the
startup fee then we had the startup
phase now we're in the scale-up phase
and then there's a post scallop phase
and it's been it's an ongoing
negotiation and we're always trying to
outweigh risks and rewards for both
partners you kind of bring the different
things to the table we have to realize
we couldn't have come to market without
them they had an established business in
the aquaculture industry and they were
doing very well they were one of the I
think they were the second largest
supplier of savage the United States so
for them they didn't need us but they
did see the future in this technology in
this innovation and the market research
that we brought they saw the the
business opportunity as well so in the
beginning I think the risk was heavily
weighed on our part because it was us
kind of bringing this forward but as
time moves on its shifting and so it's
but it is a constant negotiation because
as you're starting new technologies
things don't always work out the way you
think they are like yes we make the bio
mask and they pay for it but that price
of biomass is you know when the price of
when we had those droughts this year
with with with corn or sugar prices went
up significantly and again things
changed and and so you have to
constantly negotiate and rebalance the
risk-reward discussion so it becomes a
little bit complex is that kind of what
you were looking for I don't know if I I
would say that most people in the
industry weren't interested when we
first approached them they thought I was
too risky so they didn't think a branded
fish would work they didn't think that
consumers would care and they they
weren't they just it was too great of a
risk for them to consider but aqua chili
has always been seen as a
forward-thinking progressive thinking
salmon farmer and they did the CEO
himself saw the opportunity and he does
sit on our board to help sort of guide
our business direction and instruction
yeah
fish oil um significant difference I
would say today that the cost is not
there's no balance we are able to
produce a pretty high omega-3 leveled
yeast but we couldn't just be a
substitute otherwise it would be a very
different business model and that's
partially why we look to how do we
create value down or capture value down
the chain we do believe we can bring the
cost down over time but when you're
talking about such a new I excuse me new
idea and you're you're doing it still a
very small scale it's hard to get some
of those economies of scale so that's
something we'll hope to do in the future
because our ultimate goal is to have a
more broadly available salmon multiples
yeah sorry I can't really reveal too
much on the cost but i would say that
there's just not i mean at this point
there's no discussion i would say as the
demand goes up for fish oil the price of
fish oil will continue to increase and
that will definitely shift the dynamics
we're also continuously improving our
cell lines so we're getting higher and
higher levels of omega-3 s which means
we can use less and less than the feed
and still have the maintain high levels
of omega-3s and the salmon so we're
looking at improving the product
efficiency bringing down the cost as
well as waiting for fish oil to continue
to go up yeah
like market base agreements in the
future I mean to play that would [ __ ]
things for two towards here um well as I
mentioned before they're very well
managed fisheries and there are I'm
sorry I am I don't know if you guys ever
spent I'm pregnant and I have a little
bit of pregnant brain going on I don't
always remember the words I've tried to
think of but there are maximum harvest
levels and we have max those out so yes
those regulations significantly inform
the availability of feeder fish and some
of the reaction so the response to
limited feeder fish as the price goes up
and so then the reaction from the fish
farmers often is reduce the amount of
fish oil in the diet and then supplement
it with vegetable oil and that's when
you're going to get just a very
different quality fish and also you put
them at risk for disease now in terms of
marketing what did you say are there any
marketing I don't know because it's all
run by countries you know there isn't a
lot of international collaboration
around that yet and you know Peru gets
to set its harvest levels Chile gets to
said it's harvest levels and there isn't
actually a certification for feeder fish
even either in terms of there's not like
an MS hi did I do that there's not you
know Marine Stewardship Council is the
wild fishery certification they don't
even certify feeder fish yet so once
that comes into play then it's it could
be another different discussion on there
could be adjusted harvest levels or
whatnot I do know that the Peruvian
fishery just reduced its harvest level
for the year so we're expecting prices
to go up this year will it be maintained
or sustained not sure because it has
been shown that for wild fisheries if
you stop harvesting or reduce harvesting
significantly for a period of time the
fisheries do come back I mean in general
they will bring themselves back but it
just depends on how much how long you
give it to rejuvenate
I don't think it will ever get much
larger than it currently is and then
there's still just so much uncontrolled
fishing happening happening across the
globe in you know sort of open ocean
space anyway so it's kind of uncertainty
little warm in here did you have a
question stewardship council yeah the
ASC yes I was going to get to that but
that we've already committed to that
where we've committed to be one of the
first salmon farmers to be certified and
actually a lot of our principles and how
we raise our salmon are guided by their
165 criteria and we've participated in
the dialogues as well so and there's
they do have one of their criterias
specifically about fish and fish out and
they have a very specific way of
calculating it and that's the way we use
that's the calculation we use this from
a gentleman Albert to cone in San Diego
he developed the approach and so you'll
see there's actually when we get to the
certifications discussion there are so
many different certifications out there
right now and there's no standardization
and we've been really wishing the ASC
would have come online a little faster
unfortunately it's taken eight years or
seven years to develop the criteria and
they're not quite available for
application or use yet in the salmon
industry they are for tilapia and other
things but very very closely aligned
with them and really hope to see that
succeed I think our concern at this
point is once they get the standard out
there will the retailer's even care or
will the market care I mean it's great
for us to be certified but doesn't mean
anything at the end of the day will help
you know promote the product which then
means we can grow and actually convert
more of the industry because the
intention is to get the innovation I
think their intention is to have fifteen
to twenty percent of the industry get
certified to encourage the innovation
down with the rest of the industry yeah
yes yeah if you've been in discussions
with them how they justify that money
expect that to change well this is a big
unknown I was talking to Aaron about
this a little bit earlier so I was not
the one in the discussion and but it was
it we have had multiple discussions with
them we actually had a huge advocate
buyer inside whole foods who was ready
to bring us on and she kind of got shut
down their common is really on the GM
yeast they really don't want to support
that today I have questions around you
know they're probably fifty percent of
their products have some genetically
modified ingredients in them which I'm
curious to see now they're promoting the
labeling which is great I support
labeling as well but so how does that
highlight those products and ingredients
in their food and and i'm not sure why
they were so resistant to bringing us on
given that they do have so many products
with ingredients in their foods already
so i think it's a matter of time and i'm
hoping that there'll be some some
opening of discussion there and i'll
talk a little bit about why i believe so
from an NGO perspective we've been as a
he mentioned the ASC the AC was founded
by the World Wildlife Fund we've been
very close with them for the last eight
years in just from the very beginning of
how do we develop this East all the way
to the Monterey Bay Aquarium doing a
nine-month assessment of our farms right
now and been very very involved in
understanding our antibiotics use in our
veterinarian records and talking to the
regulatory bodies and monitoring our
diet and our feed and getting pretty
close to being a recommended like us
getting a recommended buy from them so
I'm curious how you have these two
different discussions going on where you
actually see the environmental community
seeing this as an as a good solution
versus Whole Foods taking a different
path and what the consumer will do too
because I think right now they're
looking to both of them to help guide
their decisions and and how will this
play out I have no idea so I guess that
kind of answer I don't know at you know
whole foods is whole foods i think you
know perhaps they're in a leading
position now there's a lot more for them
to lose then there was you know when
they first started off and they were
much i think in some ways more
innovative but a lot of folks we work
with are their competition and some but
some of the more smaller independent
shops that feel like they can take this
kind of risk so how am i doing on time
by the way okay um this is the good
lead-in before we when we first came up
with the yeast instead of going out and
just saying hey this is a great solution
we actually had to test it so we brought
in seven ngos we brought an EDF and
physicians for Social Responsibility and
WWF and the Pew Charitable Trust and
Friends of the ocean and all these
different groups and said hey we've got
this this solution we believe it's a
great solution for the aquaculture
industry and this is why what do you
think this was like seven or eight years
ago and they gave their feedback we
asked them what are your concerns about
having a genetically modified yeast used
in this this manner they give their
feedback around that and what this
allowed us to do is to modify our
process and how we made the yeast to
address their concerns in a way that
this is a closed containment produced
East so it's made in a closed
containment in it there's nothing left
living in the environment once we're
done with the process and so that was
one of their biggest concern so as I
know if you think about GMO crops one of
the big concerns is what happens when
you release into the environment it
takes over organic farms or takes on a
life of its own we mitigated that risk
by creating a closed-loop system and it
actually dies at the end of the process
and it needs I think vitamin B to
continue and so unless you feed at
vitamin B it stops living so that was
really important in in our long-term
strategy because the folks that we
engage seven eight years ago before we
even started talking to aqua chili are
now still our friends because we involve
them so early on in the process to talk
about how do we you know use this
technology in a way that you would feel
comfortable with then this the second
test was the fish we had to see you know
how does it impact the fish so we read a
lot number of fish lab tests at various
stages in their life cycle to understand
how does this impact growth rates how
does an impact mortality how does impact
disease how does it impact the fillet
the composition and at the end of the
day the taste we actually didn't know if
the taste was going to change and so
that was an important component as well
luckily for us people actually really
like the taste and it is unique and
different and people find it to be a
more enjoyable experience so that was a
benefit that we got added on and then at
the end of the day the final tests were
were the salmon going to eat it they're
really really sensitive creatures and so
we didn't know if they were going to
consume the yeast or not and had to make
sure that that was that they were going
to be healthy and thrive on the feet so
we did try to take as many precautions
as possible and try to bring in the
experts from both the health and the
nutrition side to understand what those
concerns would be and we continue to
commit to to the testing and
understanding of how this is impacting
our salmon we believe today that we have
lower mortality rates we believe we need
less mm biotics we don't have enough
data to back it up but our initial
hypotheses and the initial data I would
say we've been in in the water for two
and a half years and we've had fish in
the market for one year but we need to
gather some more data to really verify
and confirm these hypotheses that we've
developed but there's a number of
benefits to the yeast beyond just the
omega threes convincing the end user
that's the next line of work that had to
happen so conducting research to
understand what the consumers care about
what they value what they're willing to
pay more for providing them with the
holistic solution not just solving one
of the problems if you talk to various
consumers across the country how do you
define sustainable seafood it's always
different they have different issues you
talk to the west coast they're all about
protecting their wild salmon you talk to
the east coast it's all about what about
me the health benefits for me
antibiotics these omega-3s it's a really
different perspective I'm from the West
Coast I live on the East Coast I've seen
all the perspectives but it's it's we
can't be
1answer we have to be everything to
everyone and then that that adds on the
complexity of how do you communicate
that because depending on who you're
talking to you have to have a very
different discussion very very different
created value with differentiation and
now we're trying to capture it with
brand it's really hard trying to create
a brand in a non branded industry trying
to convince retailers to brand your fish
in their fish counter they're like but
you make the rest of my fish look bad
you know you've taken my entire
portfolio and making ninety-five percent
of it look bad just so you can look good
and I don't that's not going to work for
me so how do you help them get
comfortable with the idea how do you
educate their staff enough to
differentiate yourself and to tell the
story what kinds of support can you
provide to them how can you use
influencers and stakeholders to help
tell your story that's both on the
environmental and the culinary side and
then finally transparency transparency
transparency this industry is well known
for not telling anyone anything until
it's too late and they get really people
are just frustrated with it and fed up
with it our goal is to be as open as we
possibly can we try to address
everyone's concerns we have consumers
that right to their grocery stores about
our yeast or write to them about our
feed our customer will forward us that
letter will come up we'll just call them
up and talk to them now over time as we
have more and more of those we probably
can't talk to every single consumer who
is address you know having a concern but
hopefully by then our newsletters and
our blogs and our online discussion and
the media coverage will have will at
least address their biggest concerns and
then we can begin to you know work on
what's the next in the in that play so
did you have question
um well so just to get a little caveat I
was a wild salmon only girl West goes
girl forever and I and my partner was
too and he's recently been convinced
that now he only will only ver la so if
it's farmed but he won't need any other
farm salmon but in terms of wild salmon
one it well not necessarily it took me a
while because I was i mean i was pretty
anti farmed but I think with we went to
Portland we went to New York first in
Portland was our second market we're
like let's go the mouth of the wolves
and just really get the feedback we need
to get and surprisingly we were really
well accepted I think they had just
never seen an alternative that met any
of their criteria or or even were
considered you know worth trying a lot
of it was perception on taste so we had
to do a lot of like tastings and just
get them to try it and then they
recognize that I was talking a little
bit about the taste we're because we're
a leaner of salmon it's actually meteor
we're only about twelve percent fat
content wild Salmons about eight to ten
traditionally farmed is 18 to 24 so it's
a very big difference in our textures
closer to wild so you have this meteor
flavor and people actually associate us
closer to wild so that's been a huge
benefit but then the other thing is
we're farming in Patagonia some of the
biggest concerns about wild salmon is
the interaction between farmed and wild
salmon the disease transfer that video I
showed shared with you guys where the
wild salmon runs they were complaining
about all the farm salmon well guess
what Patagonia doesn't have any wild
salmon so that's one big thing we get to
say like and if you think about the west
coast they actually have a pretty
positive association with Patagonia
because of the wonderful clothing line
but they think of these beautiful places
and that is where we're farming so
that's a positive thing to their far
away from their precious wild salmon and
three there aren't local wild salmon
that they're infringing on so that was
some of the hurdles we were able to
overcome there's still some concerns
about introducing a you know non-native
species and all these things that of
course everyone brings up and we could
we we recognize but there are
some benefits to being down there and
and so that's been the advantage at
Portland and then I would say San
Francisco is becoming one of our largest
markets and I think that I'm hoping with
the Monterey Bay Aquarium discussion
it's going to become even a larger
market all right our story is complex
how do we make it personal and relevant
relevant to our many audiences so I've
talked a little bit about some of the
things we've done in strategies we've
done around communicating our value to
the marketing or in the marketplace but
we really for sort of focused on a
three-pronged approach and had to
develop comprehensive strategies to
engage the influencers engage the
consumers engage the business partners
because each of them have different
demands and needs and have different
questions about what we're doing and why
we're doing what we're doing influencers
were really important on the credibility
standpoint for us we had to get people
to outside of our business to validate
and say that what we were doing was good
why it was good and this is a long-term
strategy for us particularly on the
sustainability or the environmental side
these relationships with NGOs go on for
years and they're not they're not about
short-term solutions it's not about
paying them like you might a chef to say
oh this products really good like you
actually you know when working with the
Monterey Bay Aquarium they have been in
the Seafood Watch has been in business
for I don't know 1215 years something
like that and they have had farmed
atlantic salmon on the avoid category
that entire time and all of a sudden now
with working with us they're considering
moving farmed atlantic salmon out of
that category and putting it as a
recommended by and that's a huge
branding risk for them they've built
their entire brand on you know knowing
exactly what's right and what's wrong
and there's going to be and they've
convinced people they've not brainwashed
but they have convinced people why they
shouldn't buy farmed atlantic salmon and
all of a sudden there is a oh but by the
way this one's okay and so it's that's
why I think this 9 to 12 month process
with them has really been interesting
they're crossing every T and dotting
every I they asked us for reports like
10 times to make sure we send them the
same
report just like they want their there's
being incredibly thorough so that's a
long term strategy for us and we believe
that that will help us not only in the
marketplace but also help us be better
because they're always going to be
providing their feedback as well as to
what's important the culinary side it's
a little different market you know
you've got these really crazy obsession
with the Food Network and celebrity
chefs and there's the whole local
sustainable movement and I want to know
my farmer I want to be able to go see
Bob down the street and he has his
name's first chickens and that's really
different and that's great and I think
you know I come from that world it's
very comfortable for me but it's not
going to help solve some of the bigger
problems and so there we have found that
there are certain chefs not interested
because of our GM yeast and we can sit
down with them and have a discussion and
at the end of the day then you know
they're probably two different there's
probably three different paths that they
take one of them are going to say I
don't even want to talk to you you're
using a genetically modified ingredient
then the next group of people will say
you know I've seen your farms I respect
what you're doing you're really trying
to do something good but I just can't
support you I respect you I don't
support you and then the third group is
wow this is important and this is
actually a good solution to this
challenge or to this problem and some of
them has started on the left and are now
18 months later on the right and so it's
an ongoing dialogue for us but we are
engaging folks that are like leaders of
the founders of the farm-to-table
movement 30 years ago folks like John
ash in California Hugh Acheson Barton
Seaver is a big sustainable seafood
person we're bringing them down to our
farms and just educating them and say
look this is what we're doing I don't
know if any of you know Bart and Seaver
but or have heard about him or read
about him but when he came to our farms
he actually ate the feet like that's the
kind of guy he is he's just kind of
jumps right in and started thinking
about it so yeah littles I wouldn't even
eat the feet but that's just cuz there's
Cena other stuff that I wouldn't want to
eat and then the health community is
something we haven't fully tapped into
yet we do have support for physicians
for Social Responsibility but we do
believe the nutritional commentary is
probably a positive one to have at some
point we have an amazing contaminants
discussion I don't know if many of you
have
paid attention to the argument against
farmed salmon because of PCBs that was
really big about five six years ago and
actually EDF really picked up on that
and that was the way they were going to
convince consumers not to eat PCBs or
not to eat farmed salmon was because
pregnant women and children and the PCB
levels what's nice is that farmed salmon
down in Chile actually has lower PCB
levels and any farm salmon in the world
because no PCBs were manufactured south
of the Equator so number one the waters
are cleaner pure better but second PCBs
come in into the fish two ways one from
the environments where they're farmed
and two through their diet because
they're getting the feeder fish that are
growing up in those same environments so
they're getting double hit by farming in
Chile we get a double bonus one there's
none in the environment and two we have
75 percent less feeder fish so that
means we actually have we're feeding
them less and an hour our yeast is
actually super low on the contaminant
level so our PCB levels are lower than
wild fish wild salmon and this is
something that I would love to tell the
world but man that's going to be
expensive just because managing the
discussion and telling people talking
about PCBs and opening that can of worms
and not having the right support and the
credibility and all these things to
really get that story out there in a
meaningful way that people believe and
that doesn't get taken out of context is
one of the biggest marketing challenges
ever we're having a hard enough time
getting people to understand fish and
fish out let alone adding this whole
other layer of PCBs or contaminants to
the discussion so here again you think
oh wow you're doing all these great
things and you have all these great
benefits but you can't share them with
everyone and you can't actually tell in
cell what you're offering it's really
you have to be thoughtful and prioritize
what's the current message and how are
you going to convince people that this
is meaningful to them and that it's
important for the world consumers this
is just our way of categorizing some of
our targets we've done some research
who's going to think about where their
food comes from and why who's going to
ask the questions about their seafood so
we have you know awakened moms really
concerned about their children or you
know they didn't care about what they
consumed but all of a sudden they have a
baby and everything's organic
so it's it's a whole different it's a
little it's a different mindset some
belt bound are those you know 50 s plus
demographic that's all about health and
wellness they're like really living it
up the last part of their lives they're
also learning a lot from their children
their children and their 20s or in their
teens are bringing forward these issues
and bringing forward the discussions yes
oh my two minutes okay i'm going to move
a little faster and then just you guys
and then you have the channel partners
but if you think about what we have to
communicate to these to this it's all
about them and their needs all their
needs are unique for these guys it's
what's the business proposition for them
how are you you know how is this going
to make my business my seafood counter
drive more traffic how am i going to
grow business how is it not going to
make the rest of my seafood look bad etc
etc so that's really a huge challenge we
talked a little bit about the food
movement but couple of pictures up there
there's a lot about the precious food
movement I talked about it in the
beginning I'm not injured I love to dine
at wonderful restaurants I love to
experience precious food but if I go in
and work in that space I'm not going to
have a lot of impact and I'm not going
to lead a lot of change so to me being
in this other space is much more
interesting and rewarding many voices
there's no standardized sustainable
salmon eco-label available in the market
today so there's a lot of noise they
don't even all agree on what sustainable
Sam it means like I think seven or eight
of them are on this in this group
collaborative group together and they're
going to sit in on our final NBA
Monterey Bay Aquarium review which is in
3 weeks or four weeks i believe and
they're all going to have a say about
the report and the recommendation but
they don't even agree like there's you
know they might agree on like two or
three of the standards but at the end of
the day they all have different
different definitions they all have
different priorities they have different
mission statements and so they're
protecting their mission and they're
really trying to go after that so it's
it's confusing it's confusing for us to
know what's right what's to listen to
it's confusing for consumers who should
I be listening to what's what should I
be paying attention to and oftentimes
they're just going to throw up their
hands and say I don't care it's too
complex I don't want to deal with it and
so it's it's a huge challenge for us and
for anyone who's trying to do the right
thing in seafood but it's a pretty
interesting conversation but you see the
ASC is up there education tools you've
been on our website we've invested a lot
in education tools we've got videos
we've got every fish shows up with the
guilt tag in a QR code so when you get a
fish or a fillet at the store you can
scan the QR code it takes you to the
farm where the fish was harvested you
get to meet the farmer you get to know
how deep the water is what the
temperature is get to learn a little bit
more about a little closer to the farm
we can't tell you what date we're
harvesting yet but we are working on
that technology that will be the next
thing but this is this addresses
traceability issues concerns but also
gives you a little more trust in that
this is a ver la so salmon and that we
are doing the right thing personalizes
it as well recipe cards one of the one
thing about seafood is people are scared
to cook it even if you get them to buy
it then or if you get them to think
about the right issues they're like oh
but I don't know how to cook it so now
we have to teach them how to cook it
it's like oh my gosh this is a
never-ending cell and a neverending
story that you just have to reach people
on so many different levels and so we've
come up with really simple ways to
prepare fish you can see on our website
it's called in the kitchen you've got
basic techniques but then also some
simple recipes so this includes the top
10 things to know about our fish all the
sustainability points and then the
recipes at the bottom we've got a fish
wrap that are you know there's no
packaging and fresh seafood so we had to
find ways to get our messages out there
but these are just a few of things we
have a huge social media campaign etc a
fish counter on our website to help you
understand the benefits of the east and
and how many fish you can actually save
by eating salmon whether you're in one
person a family a whole city the world
these kinds of things current customer
map you were asking about this we
started off and you know maybe i should
say if people want to go you should go
and if people want to stay and ask
questions maybe i should just go there
it's almost over
it's fine it's fine why don't we why
don't we just move to questions because
then if there's still some outstanding
stuff we can address what people care
about you had some questions about
distribution we initially thought
retailers were going to be our route to
market they're much more risk-averse
though and so it's been a lot harder to
convince them so then we went to
distributors and distributors are great
because they're the ones servicing the
chefs and the chefs are independent
they're willing to try new things
they're all about the latest and
greatest they change their menus weekly
love to bring it in so that really
worked well for us in the beginning is
to really start with the regional
distribution so we got these guys you
know all these folks sort of
representing us across the country but
now it's in order to reach volume
targets or to be able to really get out
to the consumer we have to go through
the retail arm and that's where we can
really do the education because of the
chef level if there's just they're
changing their menu constantly so with a
great introduction and a great way to
begin getting our brand out there but at
the end of the day the retail is how we
get the broad visibility just wondering
if you'd look that the Kobe beef as a
similar thing and we're gonna butcher
it's the similar kind of thing not yeah
premium brand we've looked at nine and
ranch be an Estancia beef and we've
really tried to mimic that what's
interesting is that the meat buyer is
usually different than the seafood buyer
and they just they operate at very
different levels and so you have to try
to convince them that what's working in
their meat counter is working really
well and you might want to consider
adopting it there's one grocery store I
won't name it but it we walk in and it
probably has some of the most premium
products you've ever seen from coffee to
chocolate to produce to you know
whatever and their seafood is just crap
like it's just incredible and you're
just like how do you have such different
approaches to your different categories
in the same store and they just they
don't think consumers know enough to
care so it's the cheapest option and
it's the the biggest profit margin for
them we've had some folks say I like
what you're doing but I've been growing
my seafood counter eighteen percent a
year Howie you're going to probably risk
that don't you think and you know it's
it's just it's a constant discussion so
we have to build the business case for
each of them based on who their
customers are with their value
proposition or promise to their
customers are and it's it's not easy
it's really not easy yeah part of the
discussion here is that you're trying to
make the point that GM east o is
different than GM other crops rivard I'm
wondering how that's going and also
maybe you can tell us but is from you
you know GM yeast be used for any other
process that it seems to me that you do
have a chance to persuade people that GM
East because it's dead in somewhere
already you're invited and it
you can grow it and in close might get
away from sort of the general fear that
GM her genome is going to get out and
change the biosphere so let's see after
remember where we start with your
questions I don't know where new GM
yeast is being used but I do know that
we see it's like the official
categorization is we are GMM versus a
GMO and that the GMM is the
microorganism that dies versus an
organism that's continuing to live and I
know there's a number of GM's used in
yogurts and things like this I think
insulin you know we don't want to
associate ourselves with medicine but
there are a number of feed ingredients
that people don't even realize i think
reddits for cheese these kinds of things
are all GMOs so yes we could highlight
that other people are using them or that
there another feed that people want but
I don't know if we'll get enough of
people's attention to get that far in
the discussion and that's really what we
battle is how much time will people
consider the issues and and how much
will they have an emotional reaction vs.
a logical discussion about it because so
much about GM right now is the
uncertainty and the ambiguity around it
which I completely understand there is
still a lot of uncertainty around it and
there's a lot of mistrust in the
industry in general all very very very
valid and so depending on who you're
talking to your either having an
emotional or spiritual discussion or
moral discussion even in some folks
minds or you're having a scientific
discussion if you can get to the
scientific discussion it's a it's more
logical and we do find that when we get
people to sit down and listen you really
can can make some breakthroughs and
we've done that with a number of
organizations like the NBA like the
chefs collaborative and we're trying to
target these larger influential groups
to help then trickle down to the to the
consumer tough tough it takes a long
time yeah
yeah so this other side aspect that's
occurring but and in your business
you're sort of elevating the higher
quality product mm-hmm how does your
brand interact with that fact that is
the I don't know if that's good like is
the inevitability of seafood growth
increasing right or are you and you're
like tapping into this market saying
like yeah this is this is the way
markets going and we can do it better or
are you saying let's let's eat less
salmon and how to be like higher quality
no um we're saying consumers are going
to eat whatever they want and therefore
we need to provide a better option
there's something like Barton Seaver his
mantra is to introduce people to fish
they don't eat like he likes to he says
let's diversify what we eat and that's
great but that's only going to go so far
and it will have its own challenges but
right now salmon like I said continues
to grow seven to ten percent a year and
we need to find an alternative solution
and stop wreaking havoc through the
current farming practices so that's
really been our our focus area but again
as I mentioned before we do want to be a
certain size because that helps us
reduce the amount of feeder fish taking
on the ocean for the industry and reduce
the havoc from the ecosystems and
provides a better quality fish today we
are a significant premium over farm
salmon I would say like at well it
depends on where you are but fresh
direct in New York carries us and we're
like 1299 versus 999 there but if you go
to the west coast were sixteen to
eighteen ninety nine versus 10 to 12 99
just depends on who the retailer is and
how they markup things so it's people
are willing to pay that premium today
but we'll probably know over time we
want to bring that cost down by getting
cost efficiencies with the east and also
understanding our practices better and
how we can improve them and reduce costs
overall because we're testing a lot of
new things right right now and not all
of them are going to work out so we can
insert a streamliner
practices to know what's really
important for the Salmons health and the
environment anyone else yeah and I'm
also I can be here for a while so if
people want to go feel free management
strategies how you are you tester
genetically modified there's any
physiological effects on the salmon you
must have a mind for like what kinds of
things could go wrong that would look
bad organism service here's how you
think about that and so yeah so we
probably I would we test our fish more
than he want to know then you know I
know how much we do sampling constantly
in part because we're trying to measure
various things we're trying to
understand the omega-3 levels and the
uptake of the omega-3 like how are they
processing the East in their diet
because they're going to be different
depending on various factors
environmental factors or even the brood
stock from where the salmon came from so
we're testing it constantly to
understand the health of the salmon we
monitor growth rates we monitor
mortality rates were monitored disease
outbreaks these kinds of things from a
health standpoint of the salmon we are
also running tests on the benthic
considerations underneath the farm to
see what the changes are in the farm
environment but again it's all still too
new we've only had four farm site so we
don't have enough information to really
understand how this may or may not be
different than then in other situations
we are also currently sharing farm sites
with traditionally farmed aqua chili
salmon stove because we're not big
enough to have our own sites and so
they're still going to be a sort of the
the data is not going to be clean enough
yet for us to truly understand the eco
eco ecological impact but that is
something we're committed to and working
on in terms of the yeast we are
constantly testing the east if you don't
know if you guys know DuPont but they're
all about data data data like they are
kind of paralyzed analysis paralysis i
like to call them too much data and we
have a really strong safety and health
organization that's real
top of our product stewardship and we
are constantly going through reviews and
considerations around the product
stability as well as any sort of other
environmental or safety concerns around
it so it's an ongoing discussion and
process I wanted to come back to
something you are talking about G